le ministre québécois de l'éducation
déposée jeudi sa proposition pour
améliorer l'efficacité du système
scolaire et assurer la réussite des
élèves le projet doit 23 propose une
meilleure collecte de données sur la
performance des étudiants et la création
d'un Institut d'excellence en éducation
mais il donne surtout au ministre
Bernard drinville le pouvoir de nommer
les dirigeants des centres scolaires et
d'annuler leurs décisions si elles ne
respectent pas les objectifs de son
gouvernement
on a besoin d'enseignants dans nos
classes pas deux trois quatre cinq
suppléants avant le mois de janvier
il semble que pour la première fois
l'histoire on aura un véritable monarque
à la tête du réseau de l'éducation
[Musique]
merci d'être avec nous
bonjour Daniel je Réville vous avez
entendu Pascal Bérubé le monarque de
l'éducation c'est comme ça qui vous
qualifie vous dites quoi
il fait sa politique
je
moi ce que je pense c'est que c'est une
bonne idée que le ministre qui a donné
ses orientations
travaille en équipe avec les directeurs
généraux qui sont répartis un petit peu
partout sur le territoire québécois et
dans le projet de loi on va s'entendre
une fois par année sur des orientations
sur des cibles pour qu'on rame tout le
monde dans la même direction les déchets
le ministre et ça se peut qu'un moment
donné il y a un DG ou une DG qui disent
broadidé de projet particulier là je
crois pas à ça les aides à la classe je
crois pas à ça mais ça se peut qu'à un
moment donné Daniel je disais écouter si
on s'entend pas si on n'est pas pour
ramener dans la même direction et
marcher main dans la main mais peut-être
qu'il vaut mieux se séparer ça se peut
ça ça arrive dans toutes les entreprises
ça arrive dans toutes les organisations
et donc je me donne cette possibilité là
de ne pas recommander le renouvellement
d'un contrat
c'est quand même particulier parce que
ça va à l'opposé de ce que votre
prédécesseur faisait c'est pas tous les
ministres qui ont le pouvoir d'aller au
niveau local puis dire non non ça
fonctionne pas vous n'êtes pas dans
l'orientation puis vous passez à autre
chose
c'est vrai mais bon moi je propose un
autre modèle de gestion qui est fondé
essentiellement sur une approche de
cohérence de dire qu'on travaille en
groupe qu'on fait partie de la même
équipe et puis qu'on doit s'en aller
dans la même direction et atteindre
ensemble des objectifs que le ministre
fixe je pense que c'est ma job de fixer
l'espèce de vision stratégique puis
après ça s'assurer que ça se traduit par
des améliorations dans la classe que
c'est bon pour les élèves parce qu'il
faut jamais perdre de vue que l'objectif
premier c'est de favoriser la réussite
de nos élèves vous avez parlé beaucoup
des données de l'importance des données
de la vitesse à laquelle vous voulez
obtenir les données pour pouvoir
corriger le tir en cours d'année
scolaire dans votre tête ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que vous voulez les
avez à quelle vitesse ces données là
puis il y a quelle vitesse vous faites
des changements dans une salle de classe
vous voulez dire si le projet doit être
adopté si le projet doit être adopté
évidemment l'objectif par exemple pour
avoir les résultats scolaires je
souhaite les avoir avant Noël pour
justement être capable de bouger après
les fêtes d'identifier peut-être un
certain nombre d'écoles qui ont besoin
d'aide puis trouver les moyens de les
aider notamment par des aides à la
classe si on va comment dire une fois
qu'on aura les données puis qu'on saura
où sont les problèmes il va falloir bien
évidemment apporter des solutions et
puis là les solutions c'est sûr que sont
pas évidentes en situation de pénurie
c'est pas toujours évident mais il y a
des moyens quand même d'aider je parle
beaucoup des aides à la classe parce que
j'y crois et là on a un projet pilote là
on vient d'avoir les résultats là sans
écoles c'est fantastique ça marche
tempête les éducatrices aident les
enseignantes qui adorent les avoir parce
que ça fait deux adultes dans la classe
deux adultes pour aider les enfants
elles font des elles font équipe
ensemble c'est formidable alors si
j'étais capable si on est capable d'en
venir à une entente avec les syndicats
ça va beaucoup nous aider dans les
classes et dans les classes où nos
données mettons montrerait qu'il y a
besoin d'une aide supplémentaire ben on
pourrait agir notamment avec les aides à
la classe ça serait bon il y a des
enseignants où il y a des observateurs
du milieu qui disent il y a eu beaucoup
de pression au cours des dernières
années pour
pour niveler les résultats des élèves à
la hausse est-ce que de transmettre des
données presque en temps réel ça ne pose
pas le risque que il y a un nivellement
des résultats dans une classe à la
hausse pour éviter d'avoir à gérer avec
la suite des choses après Noël je fais
confiance aux enseignants puis à leur à
leur intégrité professionnelle la
situation nationale d'excellence en
éducation que vous voulez créer c'était
et vous vous donnez là encore le droit
d'orienter la formation qui sera imposée
là pourquoi vous avez le sentiment que
vous avez besoin d'avoir le doigt
là-dedans d'abord c'est 30 heures ou
deux ans ça c'est la loi de formation
continue aux deux ans pour les
enseignants dans notre réseau scolaire
l'Institut national de d'excellence en
éducation va
accréditer des programmes de formation
basé sur les toutes dernières
pratiques les pratiques les plus
efficaces les connaissances les plus
avancées
de loi j'ai le pouvoir de dire sur les
30 heures il pourrait y en avoir cinq
mettons dans tel domaine ça pourrait
être par exemple l'enseignement du
français parce que actuellement les
résultats en français sont pas
acceptables alors je pourrais oui
effectivement dire 5 des 30 heures je
voudrais que ça porte là-dessus mais
c'est pas moi qui va dicter le contenu
des formations soyez pas question que
j'aide là-dedans je connais rien
là-dedans enfin que ça va être les
spécialistes qui vont s'en occuper mais
le l'essentiel des formations ce sont
les enseignants et les enseignants qui
vont les choisir selon leur besoin et
c'est pour ça que je trouve ça très
dommage les braquage des syndicats parce
que je me dis il n'aide pas les
enseignantes en se braquant comme ça
devant la formation continue
c'est pas vrai que la formation continue
pour atteinte à l'autonomie ça va aider
le autonomie professionnelle de ce que
votre prédécesseur avait dit aux
enseignants on vous laisse déterminer on
vous laisse le champ libre sur le sur ce
que vous avez à choisir
essentiellement la même chose tout ce
que je dis c'est que je pourrais dans
certains cas
souhaiter prioriser un thème précis
parce que ça répond à un enjeu très
nécessaire par exemple l'autre enjeu
dont je pourrais vous parler la gestion
de la classe les classes sont de plus en
plus complexes avec des élèves à besoin
particulier de dire écoutez sur les 30
heures il pourrait y en avoir
quelques-unes sur la gestion de la
classe puis chaque enseignante devrait
pouvoir prendre une formation dans ce
domaine là est-ce que c'est vraiment
excessif ça Daniel je pense pas les
pouvoirs que vous donnez le droit de
regard le droit d'intervention que vous
donnez si vous ne l'avez pas votre
réforme elle ne fonctionne pas d'après
vous c'est nécessaire
l'éducation qu'on donne à nos enfants
soit encore meilleur que celle qu'on
donne présentement
Daniel Thibault c'est toujours un
plaisir merci beaucoup